[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
bonsoir est heureux de vous retrouver
pour ce nouveau 7,8 le journal voici les
titres
emmanuel macron et et à versailles hier
le président de la république a donné un
discours devant les parlementaires les
députés bernois ont réagi à ces annonces
plaisir récompensé pour sa convivialité
elle s'est vue décernée par le président
de la fédération européenne des
solidarités de proximité
le label ville conviviale ville
solidaire et puis le froid et la pluie
n'ont pas découragé les habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux ils se sont
essayés le week-end dernier un jeu
d'aventuré le koh lanta dix noix
réplique du jeu télévisé une centaine de
personnes ont participé aux festivités
qui sont selon déroulée sur le complexe
sportif du grand pré emmanuel macron
était à versailles hier le président de
la république a donné un discours devant
les parlementaires au cours duquel et la
détailler les prochaines étapes de son
action à la tête de l'état les députés
yvelinois ont réagi aux annonces du
président ils étaient près de 900
parlementaires réunis à versailles pour
écouter le président de la république
fixer le cap de son quinquennat
parmi eux 18 représenter le département
des yvelines pour les 12 députés
fraîchement élus lors des élections
législatives
ce congrès était une première marquée
par l'importance du moment et le poids
des responsabilités
une solennité particulière évidemment
d'être à versailles
l'ensemble de la représentation
nationale qui est ici nous ces dames
endroit particulier cet engagement que
le président avait pris et qu'il met en
place aujourd'hui devenir une fois par
an devant l'ensemble des parlementaires
non seulement dit que miner la vision et
le cap pour l'année à venir mais
également faire l'évaluation de son
analyse bras de l'analyse politique il a
proposé et des lois qui ont été mis en
place et tu est une excellente idée
si la forme a conquis les nouveaux
députés de la république en marche le
fond lui a divisé les parlementaires des
parlementaires visés directement par
quelques-unes des propositions des
manuels macron avec par exemple la
réduction de leur nombre d'un tiers ou
encore l'instauration d'une dose de
proportionnelle pour les prochaines
élections législatives
la difficulté constitutionnel qu'il ya
dans le bel la baisse du nombre de
sénateurs ou députés
c'est la bonne représentation est le
fait des territoires ruraux des
territoires il ya moins de monde et le
fait que le député puisse faire son
travail dans des tentes soient
raisonnables au restant bien le l'image
de la diversité de nos territoires donc
ça c'est la première éléments la
proportionnelle je suis pas une fan du
tout parce qu'on a souvent des effets
d'appareils
le paquet de réformes institutionnelles
sera voté d'ici un an selon le souhait
du président de la république et devrait
donc être actées lors du congrès épisode
2 prévue l'an prochain nous en nourrir
plaisir récompensé pour sa convivialité
le président de la fédération européenne
des solidarités de proximité a remis le
label ville conviviale ville solidaire à
la commune la semaine dernière un prix
qui valorise son implication pour
favoriser le bien vivre ensemble
convivial et solidaire
deux mots qui définissent plaisir selon
la fédération européenne des solidarités
de proximité
son président atanase périfan a
récompensé la ville pour ses actions qui
favorisent le lien social
on a en fait un ratio d'association à
plaisir pour une ville de 30 mille
habitants qui au niveau européen et le
même ratio qu'une ville de 5000
habitants fer qui a autant
d'associations à plaisir que dans une
ville européenne qui est trois fois plus
nombreuses le travail qui est fait en
termes par le service social
le projet ville solidarité qui a été
développé par exemple est assez
emblématique des mois de travail qui ont
été réalisés pour interroger les
habitants pour les rencontrer ce projet
ville solidarité lancée en 2014 prévoit
la mise en place de transports adaptés
pour les seniors un forum du handicap et
la lutte contre le décrochage scolaire
le festival escales d'ailleurs qui met à
l'honneur les différentes cultures de la
ville où les fresques du vally boues
sont eux aussi des exemples du bien
vivre ensemble des événements qui ont
permis à la ville de recevoir ce label
c'est vrai que de l'obtenir à label
européen en plus de la part de la naspe
éléphants c'est vrai que c'est une vraie
reconnaissance mais c'était important
aussi tout ce qu'on a et b devant na
fait et tout ce qui nous reste à faire
il reste beaucoup de choses à faire donc
on est fiers oui c'est un bon moment
avec cette distinction plaisir se hisse
parmi les villes les plus conviviales de
rock auprès de lisbonne prague et dublin
si vous êtes un aficionados de shopping
ouvrez bien vos oreilles le centre
commercial parly ii implantée au chesnay
annoncé l'ouverture de 13 boutiques
d'ici la fin de l'année
dans cette nouvelle extension
actuellement en construction cap nombre
déjà été dévoilé le magasin goethe
armani exchange
new balance et une boutique critchlow
spécialisée dans le bien-être objectifs
du centre passé de 11 à 13 millions de
visiteurs dans les quatre prochaines
années
on écoute le directeur du centre ces
nouvelles enseignes c'est un choix
supplémentaire ans et treize nouvelles
offres moderne très tendance très
demandé donc ça va créer une
attractivité supplémentaire
et puis ce grand programme de travaux
qu'on a vu la rénovation des parkings la
rénovation du mayet des intérieurs du
centre à rénovation des façades vont
nous permettre et c'est très important
de renforcer notre rayonnement régional
il retrouvait un point d'attractivité
sur des villes éloignées comme paris
saint-germain jouy en josas le vésinet
boulogne mieux appréhender l'accueil des
touristes en ile de france voilà le but
de deux flics touristes une opération
menée conjointement par la chambre de
commerce et d'industrie de paris et le
comité régional du tourisme pour aider
les professionnels
l'un des anges de cette nouvelle édition
la ryder cup la grande compétition
internationale de golf
elle se tiendra à saint quentin en
yvelines en septembre 2018 la ryder cup
2018 c'est pour bientôt dans un peu plus
d'un an les regards seront tournés vers
le golf de saint quentin en yvelines qui
dit compétition internationale des
affluences de public
la ryder cup cet emblématique
effectivement pour les yvelines parce
que c'est la première fois en france qui
à ce concours mondial du golf dans les
yvelines et en particulier à saint
quentin en yvelines
donc c'est ses 80 mille personnes qui
vont venir chaque jour à saint quentin
et qui éventuellement vent le soir
visiter ou revenir par la suite pour
justement visiter notre département
les retombées économiques de la
compétition sont évalués entre 90 et 100
millions d'euros la ryder cup est
intégré à la cinquième édition du 12 e
speak touristes
l'idée c'est d'accompagner les
professionnels du tourisme dans
l'accueil et notamment des touristes et
l'accueil des touristes étrangers
d'accueil c'est le sourire c'est la
maîtrise de la langue c'est le petit
geste que l'on est capable de faire
lorsqu'on sait que on a une clientèle
asiatique des plus attentive à telle
chose qu'une clientèle sud américaine
qui serait attentive à autre chose un
guide pratique un site internet et une
application sont proposés le sport
devraient continuer à attirer du public
en cas d'attribution des jeux olympiques
en 2024 pour notre portrait de la
semaine je vous propose de partir à la
rencontre de nicolas pour ce jeune
fontenaisiens à trouver dans la un moyen
de se canaliser les eaux l'un de ces
noms d'artistes est atteint de
schizophrénie
après une année passée à créer la repris
le chemin de l'emploi
un reportage de mélanie poquet et
camille lambert la morsure du serpent à
rachat de mes bras et c'est bien
amèrement que j'ai imploré le ciel de me
laisser une chance de thé vite et le
fiel avec mon instrument tout au bout de
mes doigts à l'art des poèmes japonais
et nicolas en invente chaque jour donne
il écrit
il crée et sur tille dessinée il devient
aisé aux portes et sa créativité la
peine il ya 15 ans nicolas est
diagnostiqué schizophrène paranoïde
moi je pense qu'à la base c'est vraiment
un besoin de s'extérioriser de
s'exprimer en fait et je crois
effectivement le ce aussi le
c'est une sorte de catharsis en fait ces
voies détournées
potentiellement c'est voilà trente et un
peu c'est un peu une espèce d'alchimie
en fait c'est comme transformer du plomb
en or quoi c'est la canaliser des
pulsions qui peuvent être pas mauvaises
entre guillemets mais qui peuvent être
assez violente et les traduire dans sous
une forme artistique ans nicolas willot
sportive puisque ont un petit peu de
temps là la découverte de sa maladie est
un choc pour lui et pour sa famille mais
l'acceptation et rapide notamment chez
sa mère un soutien et sa première fan
moi quand je vois les fleurs suis assez
ému parce que parce que je retrouve déjà
la patte qu'il avait qu'il avait acquise
quand il était dans son école d'art et
et en même temps je vois cette fluidité
cette aisance cette sorte de spontanéité
qu'en plus très très maîtrisée c'est la
plus belle aventure qui me soit arrivée
j'adore mes autres fils c'est pas la
question mais c'est vrai qu'avec lui
j'aurais j'ai un contact et là ça
continue un jeun contact vraiment
privilégiés on rigole énormément il a
énormément d'humour
merci
confortable à la mi-mai nicolas débute
un stage à les atrides is de plaisir un
stage conseillé par son spécialiste une
phase d'apprentissage donc je suis très
à l'écouté et c'est vrai que en fait
pourquoi j'ai pris quand même une avant
une année sabbatique
enfin voilà parce que j'étais au chômage
enfin le pro diverses raisons et donc du
coup
c'est le rythme est un peu vrai le
rythme de travail d'inscrits dur à
reprendre mais il faut se faire violence
et puis et puis ça passe ça va je
découvre complètement mais c'est
intéressant aussi mais c'est vrai qu'on
aurait peut-être potentiellement plus d'
absurde sud à apprendre des choses quand
on est jeune on paracheva j'ai 35 ans
maintenant aujourd'hui son stage s'est
transformé en cdi
nicolas travaille aux réglages lumière
pour des compagnies artistiques et
continue de créer pour combattre les
clichés
le lion's club a organisé dimanche
dernier dans le parc du château de
thoiry un match caritatif de cricket
entre les équipes de thoiry et de
saint-omer une équipe de saint-omer
composé de réfugiés afghans irakiens ou
pakistanais écouter l'un des
participants - retrouver les bonnes
équipes et les amants qu'un point
entraînements parce que j'ai tendu il
n'a pas de terrain dans ici en france
pour ça il ay la mangue un peu
entraînements sinon il ya les bonnes
équipes de fusil et le joue bien avec
vous le savez c'est dit il et un manque
un peu d'entraînement apprécié il
prendre un train une fois dans la
semaine il va le froid et la pluie n'ont
pas découragé la centaine d'habitants de
voisins-le-bretonneux ils se sont
essayés le week-end dernier à un jeu
d'aventuré look koh lanta vie si noir
réplique du célèbre jeu télévisé
les festivités se sont déroulées sur le
complexe sportif du grand pré ouvert aux
plus de 10 ans et aux adultes
regardez humeur festive et envie
irrésistible de gagner petits et grands
étaient au rendez vous dimanche pour
jouer à kolontar
pas de plage paradisiaque à l'horizon
mais la ville de voisins-le-bretonneux a
mis les petits plats dans les grands
pour reproduire ces épreuves redoutable
au programme pour ces aventuriers en
herbe jeu de réflexion d'habilité et
même un défi manger des insectes quelque
chose de familial et de convives
elle pour terminer l'année la fiche
c'était l'école est presque fini
puisqu'il reste encore une semaine et
donc s'était terminée sur une note un
petit peu festive et et sportives
et comme dans le vrai koh lanta les
équipes ont dû s'affronter pour la
finale sur la célèbre épreuve des
poteaux
concentration maximale pour rester en
équilibre le plus longtemps possible
puis vient le moment où il ne peut plus
tenir que sur un seul pied et c'est
l'équipe des nantes à nay qui savoure la
victoire du stress un peu de
concentration et au final mes collègues
sont tombés avant moi donc voilà j'ai la
chance de ne pas atterrir à un pied pas
de déception pour les autres équipes
venus avant tout pour s'amuser
les poteaux s'est très bien passé
j'étais très concentré mais quand on a
dû passer sur un pied ça a lâché j'ai va
gagner j'étais déçu mais c'était
chouette
retrouvez moi la prochaine saison de koh
lanta sur tf1
parce que je me suis plusieurs fois mais
bon j'ai toujours pas été retenue donc
j'espère que cette fois ce sera la bonne
récompense pour les gagnants une carte
cadeau mais surtout le plaisir pour tous
les participants d'avoir pu partager un
moment de convivialité
c'est la fin de ce 7 8 le journal merci
de nous avoir suivis et surtout bonne
soirée à tous
[Musique]